hi guys there's something very crazy
going on right now I'm all by
myself in this supper car this never
ever happened um
so I thought as long as there's no one
laying down over there anywhere that I
can't see the two me talking that's
thought we'd have a chat how are
you cool uh
this is awesome and terrifying at the
same time I think this has only happened
to me like twice in New York in the 5
years that I've been
here I feel like I should pee on
everything or do something fun my voice
is going a little bit um so yeah I'm
glad you guys are keeping me company
for how are your weekends so wonderful
do you like when I put the camera this
close uh I just went on an audition and
was
fine whatever I get nervous for audition
sometimes guys you ever get nervous for
things I'm a little nervous right now
actually someone's going to break the
seal okay got to go he we're at another
station oh my God I hate it